let's go to the phones 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
caller from 6 to 3 go ahead hi David
my name is Matthew I'm from Arizona
what's on your minds in a couple times I
want to know what your position is on
the terms and the vernacular of using
plutocracy or keka stock receipt to
maybe just try to describe a American
for example I think that there are
useful terms I don't think everybody
always knows what they mean so sometimes
the effective they're there I feel that
they're accurate descriptors right so
caki stock recei would be government
basically where those in power are using
government in order to achieve power and
wealth for the sake of it for themselves
I think that these are really accurate
terms but really the value and power of
a term is do other people understand
what you mean by it right and I just
don't know how understood those terms
are by the general public
yeah that's like I really called it I
would love to like probably spread this
information you know I think this
presidency
Trump's an administration that's
probably pushed more closer to the tech
Asaka see yeah yeah yeah and I think
they're good terms you know but this is
an issue of language that is a framing
issue and we've spoken to people like
George Lakoff who are really experts on
issues of political framing via language
and the right has done a far better job
than the left of using language in order
to sort of achieve the political frames
that they want and that's sort of the
risk where hey we've come up with these
really accurate not come up we didn't
invent the words but we've identified
that plutocracy and caki stock recei are
really accurate terms for what's going
on but whether they're great terms to
use or now it kind of depends on the
effect they have so I think you're
definitely on to something there ok ok I
was hoping that you're the more degrees
and to just maybe say it's more of a
conspiracy theory if anything so I'm
glad you can warn dree I did have
another question
ok oh my god you so I think you're into
sports you know you football basketball
whatever maybe you're into tennis I'm
not too sure it's it's really
interesting times for there
argentinian players right now yeah I
don't really follow tennis but there
have been some good argentinian players
and there was like this tiny little guy
whose name I forget who defeated some
guy who looked like in big reports min7
fit two feet tall yeah Diego Schwartzman
he's as tall but he's 5 5 7 yeah he's
doing really good actually being Orosco
in the first set right now I'm at French
Open so you want to watch it it's really
interesting all right maybe I'll tune in
after the show but no not a big tennis
guy generally but I do do appreciate the
call thank you very much tennis can be
exciting it's a fun game to play for me
I'm more into playing tennis than
watching it